you know ready so you've got this
dueling battle between Heaven and Hell
he's in both places and he's playing a
basketball game and the angel Beats the
devil but then he goes into a little
cheerleader
thing know which way that we
going this
way then he He makes himself into Christ
but he does it upside down which is a
satanic symbol of a a cross upside down
is not satanic but a crucifix upside
down is a satanic
symbol and they're on the
flood for in Christ his new creation the
old has passed away behold the new has
come 2 Corinthians 57 all this bad stuff
is just an attack on good stuff all
false religion is just a parody of of
the True Religion it's it's a perversion
or an inversion or an outright denial of
the true religion